à à
Xin chào các bạn
từ hôm nay chắc ơi có thời gian này mà
chữa luôn cả câu SQL đấy nóng
thì bây giờ đầu tiên mình xin phép mà
trả lời nhanh mấy câu này sau đó thì
ngày qua dạy bên giao diện để hôm nay
thực ra chẳng có cái gì tâm sự cả Chả
biết tâm sự cái gì ý
ờ ờ sau đó thì mình sẽ chữa sang bên à
SQL nóng
Ừ anh sinh năm bao nhiêu ạ Ở
thì các bạn nên rồi cái chắc ở mình có
khi phải để Linh Nga
ở tình trạng cá nhân ở trên trang của
mình thế các bạn nắm rõ
Ở đây các bạn trai một tí ra mà nó
hỗ trợ miễn phí Tình yêu là mình có vụ
chỉ có vụ chỉnh được cái playlist
em chỉnh lại cái danh sách play with a
em không có con hạnh phúc không ạ
Ừ thôi để đầu tiên trả lời các câu hỏi
đã nhé
có bạn hỏi là nên học song song nhiều
ngôn ngữ không Khi mà bạn lấy hỏi mình
về cái vụ là kiểu em đang học ngôn ngữ
này nhé Bây giờ em học cái khóa học của
anh được không nhân Vân Thực ra là các
bạn không nên học xong xong một cái gì
cả trước khi ở các bạn thực sự là kiểu
em có thể học được và
A và kiểu dạng như là chưa hoặc cả chưa
biết được là mình thực sự tích cái gì
thì chả các bạn nên học cậu à
Ông Bộ trưởng một tí biết qua nó đóng
nặng để xem cái nào phù hợp với mình còn
bề mặt chuyên sâu thì thực ra đấy như
mình nói thì các bạn nên chưa sau hẳn
cái bên là về công nghệ thông tin thì
các bạn nhưng chưa sau hả một cái Nếu mà
biết nữa nửa nọ nửa kia thôi cũng có
nghề đấy có rất nhiều nghề có những ngày
nó gọi là chuyên gia có những ngày gọi
là kiểu chuyên gia ở đây lắm trẻ chuyên
sâu hẳn mùi một lĩnh vực nhé thế là cũng
có nhiều người đã kéo dạng làm làm quản
lý làm kiểu
A gọi là đề xuất phương án các thứ thứ
thì họ là phải hiểu về khá nhiều các thứ
ví dụ họ biết qua cái nhiều ngôn ngữ và
họ biết được tác dụng của ngôn ngữ này
mạnh thế này Ngôn ngữ lạnh này mạnh cái
kia để mà đưa ra hướng giải quyết và
giải pháp đấy Nói chung là cái đấy Con
Tùy cái con người của bạn nữa giống như
mình có một ông bạn không phải bạn phải
ông bạn luôn học với máy khoa mấy người
đấy Đúng kiểu dạng là giỏi theo kiểu ở
rất giỏi về đọc đọc tài liệu cũng như
tìm hiểu sâu hơn về một vấn đề nào đó
mình thì không được như thế mình thì
theo dạng thứ hai hơn mình là một thằng
hơi bị đa-zi-năng tí đó là bây giờ Bây
giờ giả sử như bây giờ các bạn thấy là
mình mang tiếng Anh sang công nghệ thông
tin nghe mình lại nói chuyện thì có vẻ
rành mạch và có thể hiểu đi thi trình
các thứ nhà mình có thể nhảy sang nhiều
mạng khác nữa mình có thể nhảy sang nó
bạn
chỉ làm cả kế toán Tôi cũng làm được vì
tôi dọa excel không bao giờ tính toán
các thứ kiểu các
các bạn hiểu ý mình họa nghĩa là một
một người một là chuyên sâu hàng thứ hỏi
họ bất kỳ cái gì về cái Thư đấy họ đều
trả lời được còn một người thì sẽ là ở ở
dạng là công ty điển hình mình phù hợp
với mình công ty áp kiểu cửa thế hắn tỷ
ở mục là một mang tiếng là mình nhận cái
cái tiêu đề của cái
Ừ công việc của mình là công ty nó rất
buồn cười thôi Các anh khác thì đều được
là bác em van nien xong rồi cái gì đó
mục tiêu đề của cái danh thiếp của mình
có mỗi chữ Dead có mỗi chữ đẹp mà thế
này
anh Nash tất cả cậu Điền Pearl không ạ
bằng kiểu
là kiểu nhà phát triển không ạ nghĩa là
vừa thấy là nó trình lập trình cả con em
nó chỉ là papain xong rồi n thứ nữa đấy
Kiểu mình ra J5 cực xếp hứng lên có việc
gì ra cho mình đôi khi làm việc cả với
bên excel các thứ thứ
em làm việc cả bên acquire Phú Thứ
ở ngã ba xinh lắm thi công ván và mình
cảm thấy thế cũng là một lợi thế theo
kiểu là sếp rất thích những cái ông Đào
Duy lăng ở thế và Lương thì gà lương Đôi
khi lại chỉ lương thì ra lại bị hạn chế
hơn so với cái việc à Một ông chuyên sau
gia sư một ông chuyên sâu ví dụ là năm
sáu năm kinh nghiệm về T chẳng hạn ông ạ
Thế lương của họ có thể lên đến
20 30 triệu đúng không ạ Đấy con mình
thì mình thì biết giờ xử VP nhất là chỉ
được 23 năm kinh nghiệm môi trường ạ
có khi người ta chạy thì trả mức lương
em mình 23 năm kinh nghiệm nhưng nhưng
mà mình làm rất nhiều việc như mình vừa
nói nếu mà họ vẫn sĩ chạy chỉ trắng đưa
như kia cái kiểu gì thế Cái Họ hơi bị
bóc lột mình tí bởi vì công ty sát nó
vẫn nghĩ thiếu người này ra nó hơi bị
bóc lột sức lao động tí mình sẽ phải làm
những công việc nó không có tên gì cả nó
không có chức vụ gì cả phải đợi thì đông
cảo có số lượng người lớn thì chia hằn
rõ qua phòng ban phụ trách các kiểu thứ
mấy bạn hiểu minh ngọn Còn không thì bây
giờ mình anh ôm hết
Đôi khi mình còn phải người sang cả hỗ
trợ Còn bên
bên vận hành nên marketing nó cứ đùa
kiểu đấy 1 sự ra Brazil thế Mà lương thì
lương là do là năng lực của mình khi mà
nói về khả năng lực thực sự của mình làm
được trình thì nó mấy chỉ 23 năm kinh
nghiệm càng ăn thì người ta cũng Chị trả
mức lương tương đương thế thôi Cùng lắm
mà thỉnh thoảng người ta sẽ có à các
nhân viên của tháng cái gì đó đúng ạ vợ
là thằng này năng động thì làm làm thêm
việc khác thì được thưởng phụ cấp gì đó
chứ không phải là
nhưng mà rõ ra là một mình mình có thể
làm 23 công việc cùng một lúc đúng không
ạ thì nếu mà chuẩn đấy chuẩn ý thì đánh
em mình phải nhận mức lương của hai ba
người cùng lúc nếu mà mình làm như thế
đúng không ạ
Em hãy mịn các bạn hiểu ý mình
tự nhiên bây giờ vừa rồi thì chuyển qua
tâm sự một tí không sao em à Đây để cách
nói của mình đó là kiểu à à
thì mình nghĩ là nếu mà các bạn được như
thế Mình cảm thấy cũng rất là hay theo
kiểu theo kiểu nhé đó là công ty sẽ rất
cần các luận đề nghị hồi mình đi dạy học
các bạn nghĩ ra ở hồi mình đi dạy học
Mình chỉ dạy học thôi đúng không Không
mình hoàn toàn là hồi đi dạy học nói cái
này thì ra nói hơi bị những cảm một tí
về trường cũ theo kiểu sợ nói xấu trường
cũ nhưng mà nhưng mà
nó Thực ra bây giờ nó không còn tốt đẹp
trong mắt mình nữa ra là mình cứ nói nó
Kiều
cơ hội Mình đi dạy mình một mình mình
làm cả cái phần mềm của trường phần mềm
điểm danh quản lý sinh viên nói chung
đầy đủ tất cả thứ
anh
nói chung nhà Đấy cũng là một trong
những công việc không tên của mình đó
làm gì ạ Mình làm cả cái phần mềm cho cả
trường dùng quản lý điểm cho nó chụp đùi
thứ nó không ạ Đấy và mình chặn về sau
thì mới được công nhận một tí một tí với
nhé
về giá bèo bọt thật sự ra bèo bọt theo
theo kiểu lá không có hẳn không hẳn có
tiền lương gì cho cái việc hạnh cho việc
đấy bằng tía đến bây giờ chưa mà vẫn
dùng khi mà mình mình nghỉ vợ cũng là
cho trẻ 15 nhưng mà cũng 10 tháng rồi
nhờ trường bảo là sẽ có phần mềm mới thứ
không mua lại phần mềm của mình nữa đấy
mới vẫn dùng rất buồn cười em
ở trường cũ của mình thì nói thẳng ra
thì nó giống như là công ty nó là công
ty tư nhân nên là nó hơi bị nó hơi bị
cậu nó đặt à
anh đọc kiểu dạng là kiếm tiền là trên
hết chứ không phải là kiểu à
em học sinh là trên hết không phải giáo
dục và trên hết đi
Ừ tôi mà bóc phốt người có trường tôi sẽ
không biết thế nào
Ừ thôi không nên bóc phốt ở đây chúng ta
đến kiểu
khi sex
em không nên làm thế
Ừ chắc ông kia biết à Ông Kiều khi vẫn
là sinh viên của trường trường tôi đúng
Ừ thôi đừng có khóc phút nhé
Ừ
ok lại quay trở lại nhé
ờ cuối tuần này các nhóm nộp bài theo
cách nào ạ
Các bạn Đăng linh tính kết hát nhá các
bạn sẽ nhưng mình nó là các bạn về nên
làm việc ghi thấp Chắc là có một buổi
nào đó mình sẽ mình sẽ kiểu hướng dẫn
các bạn sử dụng cái clip mà mình đang
dùng khá tiện khá thiện và mình cũng chỉ
các bạn cách mà để mà Bởi đầy cốt lên vi
cốt ở ghi chú thích như nào bình thường
hay làm thế
Ừ anh thì đang vào bóc phốt À không mình
bởi vì à mình cũng có lương tâm một tí
ẩm thực ra không phải lương tâm về trước
đâu mà sự thật như thế họ đối xử mình là
xinh mà cậu báo lồ mình khá nhiều từ
lương rất là cao lương Hồi đấy bởi vì
một phần học phí thì sinh viên cao lương
mình hội rất là cao
Ừ nhưng mà mình cảm thấy là
anh chả lẽ mình nghỉ việc ở đâu đó rồi
mình đi nói xấu về cái nơi cũ của mình
ra đấy làm cái một con người không phải
con người trưởng thành theo thì hết
nhưng mà nhờ mình thỉnh thoảng mình sẽ
nó vài cái đậu Nó không đúng vài cái
kiểu họ Lên Kiểu xem xét lại giống như
cái mình vừa nói đó làm gì ở họ phải họ
là trường học thì họ phải tôn trọng sinh
viên ít nhất như thế giáo viên thì có
thể bóc lột không làm gì được như họ
phải tôn trọng sinh viên không ạ ạ
Ừ ok Ờ
vịt hấp thì Private hay là public ở
thì tùy các bạn thôi Thực ra là các bạn
nên để lắp nick cũng không sao
và các bạn cũng inbox Không phải ý Magiê
mà chat trong cái canh đấy thì mình mình
và mình xem mà cũng được không ạ Chắc là
chẳng ai biết được cái tài khoản ghi
thấp các bạn vào xem đâu còn quay vết
thì các bạn lại phải mất công
thêm mình vào đúng không ạ Thế mình vào
thì mình mình không biết mình nói các
bạn chưa đó là mình quen việc là
khi sử dụng một cái nick em ở mọi nơi
đây như thế này mấy ông cứ tra thì cái
này gọi là cây chò biệt danh đúng không
ạ username đúng không ạ Ở trên Google sẽ
ra rất tất cả
những cái thử liên quan tôi những cách
mạng xã hội của anh tôi cả khi tháp cao
thứ chứ Thì mấy ông trà và mấy ông chọn
thêm cho ta cũng được
Có ai biết hình như không còn mất phí à
hồi hồi trước là
anh cũng không Hồi trưa là không mất phí
Nếu mà dưới ban hành Nếu ba người
Em không biết được à Bây giờ là như nào
nhưng may có shop mua lại hình nhờ tôi
thấy à
Ừ nó tăng cái giới hạn người lên rồi mà
Ừ ok chạy tiếp nhé
admin cần những quyền gì ạ thì thôi các
bạn này hỏi thế không chắc là bạn đang
nói với bài toán phân quyền hai cái thứ
nhưng mà để nói rõ hơn người vụ này chắc
là mình sẽ Phân tích kỹ hơn sau thì thứ
bảy này các bạn nhiều nhé các nhóm nhiều
nhá đó thứ bảy này mình sẽ à
anh
nói chung và cư cuối tuần thường ngày
thứ bảy chủ nhật thì mình sẽ thường ai
nhắc nó là
mình sẽ bàn về cái đồ án được mạng Thứ
bảy này nhá Thứ bảy này mình sẽ bàn cụ
thể là lần đò này mình sẽ phải phân gọi
là dùng từ lại phân tích thiết kế ở Đông
ạ Các bạn nhớ vụ cái water for hôm trước
không ạ đó là chúng ta phải làm cái
design trước trước khi mình nhờ cốt để
ông ạ thì bây giờ tôi vẫn chưa bắt mấy
ông Cốt Xem thêm sửa xóa hết các thứ là
hoạn mới chỉ làn da diện cũng là một cái
chữ thiết kế thôi là thiết kế Trương
giao diện không ạ thì thứ bảy này sẽ
hướng dẫn cho mấy ông về thiết kế được
tiên là thiết kế sơ đồ quan hệ thực thể
này và thiết kế tài liệu em viết tài
liệu là phân tích
khi chúng ta phải có phân tích rồi lý
thiết kế đúng ạ phân tích xem là có
những người dùng gì ở trên trang web
không ạ Người ấy sẽ làm được những tính
năng gì nóng lạnh thì thì cả đấy chứ là
quyền của những ngày người dùng đấy ví
dụ khách hàng thì làm được những gì
khách khách thì có mấy loại này admin Có
mấy loại chẳng hạn đấy tôi sẽ phân rõ
dần dần ra các bạn hình dung rõ hơn Nói
chung là cư cứ mấy ngày trong tuần thì
tôi sẽ dạy các bạn kiến thức để các bạn
biết cách làm các bạn có thể là từ đấy
có thể ngồi làm trước một ít sau đó thì
khi mà đến khi mà đến thứ bảy hoặc hoặc
chủ nhật cuối tuần tôi sẽ hướng dẫn các
bạn về đồ án để các bạn sẽ ghét mấy cái
cốt kia vào trong đồ án của mình đúng ạ
ừ ừ
Ừ ông sợ tài liệu tôi tưởng Ông mấy ông
đều sợ cái trình cả ngày không sợ tài
liệu thì đấy một cái thứ rất là nhỏ ạ
ở thời gian Nói chút về mát không biết
bạn này nói mát làm mát cái gì là bản đồ
ạ Nhớ bản đồ cho cũng biết đâu nhé hồi
nhờ tôi nhớ hồi trước là tôi học thuật
toán về ma trận hay các thứ thứ tôi quên
sự gần hết rồi
ừ ừ
Ừ thế ơi hỏi Ưu điểm về à
Ừ cái cái này của bạn đấy đại khái nó là
ưu điểm của Acquy Oh so với mẫu atwell
là gì Các bạn tra Google thôi K có các
bạn thường hay tra từ khóa rằng ngắn ví
dụ ở đây AK Wen vs nấu với cu em nó sẽ
đề cập cho các bạn với ưu và nhược điểm
thì để mình nói khái quát ra thì đại
khái nó là
khi FBI và có cấu trúc còn nấu SQL không
có cấu trúc đúng quá Tức là sao nghĩa
làm chị ở tháng này thì có ràng buộc các
thứ thứ có cấu trúc kiểu để mà kiểu đi
nhập vào nó sẽ kiểm tra
à Còn cái Hà Nội kia thì kiểu mình nhập
vào Ninja tinh cũng được cho ra hai
thằng nó sẽ gỡ ưu và nhược điểm khác
nhau một thằng thì có yêu làm chỉ là dữ
liệu mà sẽ gần như là luôn đúng và nó sẽ
nối roi nhau Cá thứ thứ à Còn cái thằng
lâu ếch leo này thì lắm chị ạ Mình lưu
thế nào được Thế nay câu chuyện truy vấn
Cũng nhờ có lưu là sự rất là nhanh nha
mà nó không nói gì cả nên là lưu lại nó
sẽ dài dòng đấy mình nhớ là như thế mình
thì da mình chưa sau về cái nó với áo
nên là mình không để cập thêm được
em có mẹo nào để tạo maythu để xài máy
tool của Jack lên tới K có mấy cái trang
để mà Hỗ trợ đăng ký tạo maythu rồi miễn
phí
Ê mày ông có cha là có nếu mà tôi thì
tôi may mà tôi
ở gần đây Thật ra tôi cũng bị vô hiệu
hóa cái tài khoản merdu ở trường cũ vì
tôi không có đi dạy nữa thì tôi may mà
tôi học liên thông thì tôi lại xin được
cái mail khác nếu anh còn đang đi học
thì mấy ông cứ xin đủ trường đấy ông ạ
Midu như tôi từng nói rất là tuyệt rất
có lợi đăng ký rất nhiều cái hoa cả mấy
ông còn hôm trước tôi Black Friday không
ạ Tôi dùng sửa mayoto
Email cho bên A khỏi bên giáp Renault
như một bên A để mà tôi
Ai cho xin giảm giá cái khóa học lario
về khóa học nâng cao về Core i
đi đái thế họ giảm giá cho thêm thành ra
tôi được bình thường giảm giá 40 phần
trăm tôi giảm giá thành 70 phần trăm à
Ê
mấy ông chỉ cần đặc biệt là mấy ông kiểu
nói tiếng Anh hiểu không cần được chú
chạy đâu tiếng Anh cho nhát gừng tính
nhanh kiểu Sai chính tạo được người ta
sẽ càng nghĩ càng tin tưởng ông hơn ông
cứ đầu câu đầu tiên của ông ông bảo Việt
Nam ít chứ không ạ hấp dẫn
chi tiết
Ừ ok phần phần data pay bại của bạn vừa
hỏi mình Sao lại phần đã tao bay là mỗi
nhóm tự thiết kế
rồi thầy sửa hai thầy cho sẵn cái này là
Ừ cái này là mình à
mình sẽ kiểu thiết kế một cái cậu một
cái một cái khuôn trước và các bạn hoàn
toàn thể bổ sung hoặc là thêm gì đó mà
mình Và và đương nhiên là mình sẽ có
thời gian để chốt Doctor bai có bạn và
khi mà chốt xong thì ngữ nói đó là các
bạn không được cách sửa Đông ạ Cái nhưng
mà cái việc là các bạn tự thi kể thêm ý
thì các bạn cũng sẽ phải nêu rõ lý do Là
tại sao bạn thi kể thêm như thế
có thiết kế đa tam.bai là đều phải dựa
trên các chức năng mà các bạn muốn làm
đúng không ạ là sửa các bạn muốn làm
tính năng bán hàng đương nhiên à Phải
phải có bảng để lưu lại cái hành các bạn
đã bán trả nợ đúng không phải lưu lại
hóa đơn đúng
Ừ nếu mà các bạn làm trang tin tức mà tự
nhiên các bạn đã có cái bảng bảng hóa
đơn thì lại toàn quá đúng không ạ chả
liên hoan gì cả đấy Kiểu vợ Thế ngắm chị
ạ Toàn bộ những đã sân bay và đều phải
dựa trên chức năng mà các bạn muốn làm
không Không có việc là thêm hạn một cái
bảng hoặc thêm hẳn một cái cột thừa nó
mà không có lý do nó không phải để cho
vui không ạ Em em thấy nhóm khác có cái
đấy thì em bắt chước không không không
có chuyện đầy nó ạ thì mình sẽ phải có
cột hoặc có bảng Thì đó đều dựa theo
chức năng mà mình muốn
em còn đi nha các bạn lúc đầu các bạn sẽ
không biết thế Kể gì Các bạn sẽ phải cần
mình sửa đâu ạ Mà mình sửa xong thì như
nói là mình sửa xong rồi phải chốt đúng
không ạ Không phải sửa xong rồi các bạn
lại lại hôm sau lại em mẹ muốn làm thêm
tính a VC em quên chưa kịp nói với anh
Em cứ sửa trước đã thế là toa ngồi đúng
không ạ
à à
Ừ ok học cho mẹ Trang nào ạ nếu mà các
bạn
thực vật về sau mình sẽ gợi ý các bạn
rất nhiều trang để mà các bạn học chuyên
sâu thêm Còn hiện tại thì các bạn mới
học cái này thì mình sẽ chưa thể nào là
hướng dẫn các bạn nhiều cái trang điểm
chuyên sâu được Bây giờ chắc các bạn chỉ
biết về mỗi Nếu TPP chứ hát Alo các bạn
biết lưu pass School Idol Kids
w3school không ạ
code academy ra nó quá tốt rồi và thích
thì các bạn thêm medium đọc thêm rất
nhiều cái nó không ạ lại chế này cũng có
rất rất nhiều lập trình viên ghi trên
này đã dạy sáng thế và sắc đâu lâu thì
có phổ biến rồi không ạ Nhưng cái này để
mà hỏi hỏi nhiều hơn và cuối cùng là nếu
mà trang của người Việt thì nó vibro
hoặc cả à a
perilous ngoại nhưng mà cái này thì 22
cái này thì nó vẫn hơi nâng cao một tí
không ạ
Ừ thế thì nên là mình nghĩ là về về sau
các bạn muốn thì mình sẽ gợi ý thêm gợi
ý thêm mấy cái khóa học không hẳn là
khóa học mà chẳng qua là những cái kể
những cái video họ chia sẻ kinh nghiệm
của các thứ thứ
khi nào mình sẽ mở cho bạn thử một cái
ra đấy Khi mà sang khóa nâng cao thì các
bạn sẽ thấy họ tối ưu câu truy vấn tượng
trưng là kiểu 3 giây đối với mình ở
nhanh rồi Họ biến anh 0,3 giây như nào
đấy thì thì họ sẽ tối ưu như thế nào Tư
duy họ như nào không ạ
Ừ hi vọng nấu mình mở cái không nên có
bị đánh bạn quyền không ạ
Ok Thôi bây giờ bắt đầu bài học hôm nay
nhé Hôm nay thì tôi mụn thì mình muốn
cho các bạn là là cậu làm một trang web
kiểu dạng mà hiển thị ra và giao diện
của khách hàng không ạ Cũng trước và
mình làm do diện của bên A không phải
giao diện mà gần như hôm trước mình chỉ
làm các tính năng ở bên là ăn mì thôi
Nhưng mà thực ra thế cũng làm tính là
cậu giao diện tương đối rồi đấy ạ nhưng
mà còn bên khách hàng đi nha các bạn
thấy phải màu mè hơn rồi nó thứ Thì bây
giờ mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn ạ
ừ ừ
Cài đặt giao diện khách hàng các bạn Thu
sơ quá nóng hôm trước làm về sản phẩm
rồi ngoan bây giờ mình cần có bao nhiêu
sản phẩm Nó sẽ hiển thị bấy nhiêu ở đây
giao diện màu mè hơn chẳng hạn
thì các bạn thể chia làm các Deep các từ
từ cũng được ạ là mình giả sử mình sẽ có
khái niệm ở đây là thì sẽ có cái đít vào
đây là mình chia bố cục cho trang web
Chữ anh ạ Các bạn nhớ về cái vụ hồi đi
dạy về cái á
xe tải đi trên này kiểu đây ra sự đi
trên dưới ấy ngoại
anh sữa và đi từ ấy ở lại ạ
anh
lắm rồi không đi lại xe không ạ
này
tạm ngay đi
Ừ Ok đó ạ sau đó đi mình sẽ có clip trên
à
- xã Vinh trả lại ạ
ừ ừ
à à
À
mà tôi sẽ là 70a
ở những giữa này
là địt dưới á
à à
anh nói kiểu Nga đầu tiên mình sẽ có
chia bố cốc trước nó không ạ thì bạn bạn
thân là cái đít trên này của mình nó sẽ
là kiểu nó chứa cái máy nude không ạ thì
mình có thể là
mình sẽ
ở gần gần như cả toàn bộ những cái à
ừ ừ
an toàn bộ gần như là mình nhảy sang
trang abc.xyz đây là tôi thường ví dụ
trong một cái trông dễ hiểu đi
không nói nói mồm thì mấy ông ấy không
hiểu lắm
Ừ thế thôi Vào trình thời trang Để ủng
hộ tôi nhé
khi tình yêu bị đo ở đây
Ở đây các bạn sẽ thấy ở trên là mày ngu
đó ngoại sôi giữa là nội dung này xong
rồi dưới là Scooter này đúng ạ khi bấm
vào một cái sản phẩm như thế này chẳng
hạn không ạ bấm vào một sản phẩm này thì
các bạn thấy là ở trên là vẫn sẽ giữ
nguyên ở dưới nó vẫn sẽ giữ nguyên của
bọn nó sẽ chỉ quan tâm nó việc là thay
đổi cái ở giữa nóng mặc thì bây giờ mình
sẽ làm đúng kiểu bố cục như thế thì có
phải trên này có có giữa này có ở dưới
đúng không ạ Rồi các bạn sẽ sửa cái trên
này sẽ có logo xong rồi Ở bên này có cái
Menu Vân của ngọn sau đó thì ở giữa này
thì là vẫn giữ nguyên giữa này là bước
thì điều gì tùy các bạn ngoặc Em ở Phú
tô các bạn làm sau đó thì các bạn bấm
Sang trang khác thì gần như là cái giữa
thay đổi các bạn chỉ cần tạo ra cái file
vỡ thôi không tạo ra những cái file ở
kia nữa và các bạn sẽ in Plus những cái
file file menu để file các thử thử và bị
sẽ cho các bạn làm như kiểu đấy à
à à
Ừ nó bạn hình công ạ Bây giờ mình sẽ đổ
Làm bây giờ sự là mình có cái Menu gì đó
ừ ừ
đ.l đi này thì sẽ thấy a đây này
như là cậu tất cả sản phẩm ra lại ạ
Tik Tok trang chủ để tranh
trang chủ
Ừ thì nó sẽ để trang Index chẳng thấy
tên này à
anh đi kiếm gì hay mà các bạn làm chúng
có thể là cho nó nhập nữa chẳng hạn trả
lock-in thế này đây là đăng nhập
cảnh như này đúng không ạ và các bạn sẽ
vứt cái này vào một file nó phieu này à
ừ ừ
ở bàn yêu mình đã nói hôm trước là mình
sẽ in Plus cái file này
mày nu.tp này
các bạn thấy ta cốt nó vẫn giữ nguyên
không ạ Đấy tiếp theo mình sẽ có file
food to hơn nữa à
cha mẹ vứt cái này vào này ạ
Ừ
ở đây cũng sẽ là chậu có gì hết Chỉ có
bạn không ạ
à à
ở nhà cái
888 uy tín hàng đầu Việt Nam là à
Anh ở mặt chữ rồi
quên chữ in groups
in plus ở đây này à
Anh nói như thế này đúng
thì tại sao đó đi
thì mình sẽ sửa cái giữa thôi ông ạ
Nếu mình nhớ không lầm là khỏi đấy mình
chưa bố cục là mình sẽ tách ra ở đây sẽ
là mình sẽ tạo một cái file ở đây mình
mại tạo cái file đó là kiểu của
cài đặt tên nó gì con tê
tê tê
Anh thường là mình sẽ là tên như này
anh hoặc gà các bạn để tên là khô đắng
cũng được như này lắm chưa có tất cả sản
phẩm nó sẽ nằm ở giữa như thế này cũng
được không ạ
ô ô kìa tôi không không quảng cáo nhé
tôi không Bơ sung không ở Quảng cáo cho
chị đang trêu thế thôi
Nếu chưa nghe cái đấy bây giờ
thế Chứng tỏ họ không xem phim lộng
nhiều rồi
ở
bên đấy à
ờ ờ
White
Thực ra cái file con nick này đang nằm ở
trong thư mục thăm Min không ổn lắm về
phía Thực ra phải con nít này dùng mà
mọi nơi đúng ạ Mình mình đẩy nó ra ngoài
hợp lý hơn nha Mà thôi lỗ chốt ở chỗ
khác có rùa nhưng làm thôi mình lại phải
vẫn gọi đến chậm nhai đương nhiên cái
này nó không liên quan đến quyền gì cả
Không có Không cần phải đăng nhập vào
liên kết được cái file này như thế nó
không ạ ạ
Ừ
ông cho biết à Chứng tỏ là ông không xem
phim lậu rồi Xem phim bộ nó còn nghe
nóng sẽ quảng cáo mới cái nhà cái kiểu
nhé đại khái như thế Mày không hiểu gì
đâu mà đi
à à
ở
đây cậu ngay đây lấy tất cả các sản phẩm
sau mình sẽ lấy nó ra cái quan trọng
mình in ra thì như các bạn đang thấy ở
trên chai này của mình là mình sẽ in ra
theo kiểu lại 3 sản phẩm ở trên một dòng
sông đó xuống dòng cách giải quyết của
cái của cái làm này chứa nóng rất là đơn
giản theo đó là các bạn thể chia cái
chấp này nó là 33 phần trăm chẳng hạn
tại thế để mở khi mà nó đủ 3 gái nó sẽ
đầy xuống dưới thế thôi thường mình hay
làm như thế nào đương nhiên là trong nó
thực ra nó không được đẹp lắm theo kiểu
là nó không đi bar ship thì cả nó không
hẳn là chuột nghe thôi mình có làm đại
khái như thế nhá thì tức là có bao nhiêu
sản phẩm in 7 nhiều ở đây 7 nhiêu cái ít
này là bị sút này có bao nhiêu sản phẩm
này à
xe máy điện Duy 57 nhiêu clip và mình sẽ
có đít ở đây mình sẽ có class cho nó là
rượu lại từng sản phẩm em ạ
từng sản phẩm như anh điều tiết hơi khó
chịu nha được tạm chấp nhận Nga Mỹ thể
freesize thế này được không Sao ạ
em với từng sản phẩm thì mình sẽ có hít
là ba mươi phần trăm tệ nạn này
ừ nó đó Thì bây giờ mình có thể hát một
cái trôm một cái rõ to ở đây là nem nha
sẵn
tại tra này
ạ Bây giờ ta có một sản phẩm không ạ bây
giờ sự là mình có 34 sản phẩm gì đó đi
là sửa mình sẽ đáp đi Kết thằng sản phẩm
lên bốn cái thì các bạn sẽ hiểu tờ
ở đây ma mi hót ạ
cho bộ đồ cho nó đi
bạn hình dung qua vậy được sẽ nằm trong
cái viền như nào xong rồi các thứ hai
cho nó là 200 Tết này chẳng hạn
nó như này
mẹ chồng hơi xấu nhỉ Nhớ đợi tí thôi chị
lại
anh ở đây sẽ có email này à
à à quên quên quên
à à
Em email này sẽ nhảy đến A cái đoạn này
nó lại hơi bị sâu mình tí giống như hôm
trước mình bảo là thực ra nên để cái thư
mục ảnh ở ra ngoài cùng một mình không
thì mình sẽ phải đến admin này chụp chéo
này sao đến khô đắng này như thế này cái
này nó khá nguy hiểm với cái này người
dùng chonso người ra thể xem được có
đường dẫn chứa admin rồi Nó lại tò mò nó
lại tộc mạch không ạ đương nhiên về sao
mình cũng có chặn quyền đăng nhập vào
mới được vào nhưng mà ra thế này trong
để lộ đường link rồi Thật ra nó trải
nghiệm không được tốt lắm rồi người dùng
vẫn có thể hiểu biết đâu mà mò mẫm đã
được một cái thư mục nào đó
của ông nóng hoặc thì khả năng nguy hiểm
à
à à
ừ ừ
Em
nói như này
à Tôi đang để mô xe thôi nhé mày ông sẽ
thấy nó trông rất tàn nhang và xấu không
ạ nhưng mà người ông đừng có đòi hỏi gì
cả Tôi không dạy mày ông truyền để giao
diện ông ạ
à à
hai
iPhone 13
[âm nhạc]
à à
anh gọi
ở
Samsung à
đại khái như này thôi em ạ ạ
em
gọi cho dài dài em tí để tí nữa không
xem
à À quên có phải có cái này nữa
à à Mày có 2 sản phẩm nha thêm một sản
phẩm nữa nhé Thì chạy gần phát nữa lại
thêm 2 sản phẩm giống hệt nhau này kê
bây giờ sẽ có tổng cộng là
Ừ anh nhớ là không được trùng tên được
anh ở đây vẫn được này đúng rồi chưa sản
phẩm mình không để unique có mỗi mà nhà
sản xuất thì mình để unique tên thôi Chứ
không bây giờ có nhiều sản phẩm không ạ
Các bạn thấy nó bị thu xuống dưới Các
bạn nhớ dạy cho ông ạ đối với khi mà cái
đít đi tìm mặc định nó sẽ bị trôi xuống
thì mình thêm flash đúng không flash sẽ
trôi nằm sát cạnh nhau như thế này
ở đây nó sẽ như thế nào đó
trong cùng một anh mấy ông chồng hơi xấu
không ạ Thôi kệ đi
Thì bây giờ mình mình Các bạn thấy chưa
bố cục kiểu như thế này không ạ để mặc
khi mà mình bấm vào bây giờ chưa xem
được cái phần là mô tả đúng không ạ
hai tay thiên thập phân giá nhé bị thêm
cái giá đây này ạ
anh ở đây sẽ có echo ở đây
là Faiz giá đúng không ạ thì Đô la làm
sau trong vệ sinh này nha trở lại cái bị
trụi chui xuống buồn vì ạ Cái này cái
ảnh nó đẩy Cài chữ này xuống mà hơi bị
cả đoạn này gộp lại nữa to hơn cái chiều
cao mà Mấy ông thể chỉ lại giao diện sau
lại khá như thế này cho tăng lên tý
không Ok tôi chị ạ đấy
ăn chuối xấu vãi à
Ừ nếu mà Mấy ông thấy thử cá trôi như
thế này nó không tốt về thứ nhất là nếu
sẽ ít sao như này mà người ông cho cái
nách lúc đầu nó là 700 như này thì nếu
mà về sau nhiều sản phẩm quá nó sẽ bị
trôi hẳn ra nó không ạ Nên là mấy ông
nên làm cả phân tranh của phân tranh ở
đây em chị ạ trang trang này nên có 6
sản phẩm Thôi cho chồng đẹp nặng sau đó
thì bấm sang trang 2 nó sẽ 6 sản phẩm
tiếp theo đúng ạ sau đó mình làm cả tìm
kiếm thứ thứ nữa đấy
ở đó xong rồi đại khái là bây giờ mình
sẽ có nút để nó xem thêm này thì bấm vào
sẽ xem cụ thể với bài đăng này đúng
không ạ Cái mô tả của nó thì như nào
mình sẽ thẻ đây không ạ
Mình sẽ nhảy lên cái file mình thường ai
đặt tên là view details rồi cái gì đó
dễ
thương mà ví dụ ở mình đặt tên có thể
khô đắp chấm pp đây rồi kèm theo ID
intro thích cái mã này để xem cụ thể
cái sản phẩm theo mã của cổ cái bài đăng
đấy nhưng mà
xem chi tiết này lại nhìn trông cậy kích
thích nha nó
Em bấm vào thì sẽ là nhảy liền thời
trang này đúng ạ thì trang này mình làm
như nào cái là nó cũng ngỗng sẽ được thả
giống cái Trang đấy đây mình đây mình sẽ
topic lên thì các bạn thấy
nó sẽ chỉ khác nhau việc là Plus cái
việc in Plus này mình đổi nó thành phô
đắt thế này là xong
ta0 mình để tên này trùng mất rồi nhỉ
ngừng đập vĩnh viễn
nhìn đặt tên như nào nhỉ à
à à
khi đôi khi ở Tôi hơi đau đầu với vụ đặt
tên một tí bởi vì về sau thực ra mấy ông
không phải lau vụ đặt tên này lắm
Ừ thế thời cố tuần này đặt tên nó bị
lằng nhằng có hơi nhiều file đầu các bạn
cái inplus đống mà thế là trông có vẻ
làng anh ạ
em tôi đặt tên file đây ai đi không biết
tên gì nữa tạm Để tên như thế nhá anh
bước đi theo à
Cũng được Cũng được
ở
đây thì file Thực ra khá giống cái sai
này theo kiểu là nó cũng có cái đoạn kết
nối này nhớ là giao diện rất là nó sẽ
khác rồi nó diện lần này sẽ đẹp hơn rồi
đoạn này sẽ có ai đi vào đôla get
ID đồng ngoại
Ừ cái này mình sẽ nghe
hay đi bằng
đôla đi này mà mình sẽ lấy mỗi thằng
đầu tiên đi trở lại
nha Và bây giờ mình sẽ vẫn ở đít giữa
vẫn phải nằm trong Đứng giữa là ngọn
nhưng mình không có cái đi về nữa nó sẽ
to hẳn như này như thế này
anh không có xem chi tiết nữa để bọn
mình sẽ chỉ có thể bây ở đây đây trâu ở
đây là ít tại description là nội dung
này họ trong việc nhai đó
ở trong không đẹp Tôi biết cho rằng
không đẹp bởi Tôi không dạy cho ông chưa
giao diện bọn mày Ông đừng có làm giống
hẹp tôi như này ra được mấy ông sẽ phải
tự chỉ ngại ra diện nhưng mấy ông hiểu
đi thôi ông ạ Đấy khi bấm vào trang chủ
thì nó quay lại này bấm vào xem chi tiết
này nó sẽ kiểu ngay đúng không ạ Nếu
không thấy thì ra sai bây giờ nó Cốt nó
cũng không hẳn và dài lắm một file này
nó sẽ gọi file kia như thế này lại khái
nó mô hình nhiều kiểu như này nó sẽ chia
nhỏ nhỏ các file đưa dầu gọi nhau như
thế này đúng ạ nó file file trang chủ gì
nó sẽ là tự nhiên luôn có menu vậy thôi
gọi đến tất cả sản phẩm là sau đó gọi
đến router này phải sản phẩm Tất cả sản
phẩm từ các động rất ngắn không ạ Cái
các thứ
ý mẹ mấy ông hiểu được đoạn này chuyện
nữa là mình sẽ chia chưa nhỏ như thế này
ra để mà quản lý thế là cái file CS này
các bạn thấy Thực ra cũng gặp lại cốt
này mình có thể tấm cái này ra một chỗ
khác nữa này Tống hẳn cái xông mình sẽ
in Plus nó về đúng không ạ
Cái này nó chưa hẳn là cái gọi là mộng
một mô hình gì cả Không hẳn mô hình gì
cả trẻ trên nhỏ ra thôi Còn cái mô hình
về sau mình sẽ dạy các bạn thì ví dụ mô
hình pc nặng thì các bạn sẽ hiểu rõ hơn
để nó vừa chia nhỏ nó vừa là một mô hình
chuột đó là như thế nào ạ
Ừ ok
anh ấy biết rồi Tôi đã để mua qua cho
mấy ông về trang câu chuyện của khách
hàng đấy ông ạ Nó cũng không ăn là tiên
đối gì đó ghê gớm không ạ Còn đăng nhập
cái ông tự làm nhưng form đăng nhập với
mấy ông tự Quốc hội mạ Oppo trên mạng
được
Em hãy dưới phút Ơ mày có đường link gì
đó không ạ À đây thanh menu được có bấm
xem mà giỏ hàng nó thử nữa cũng được đi
Anh Em có thắc mắc gì không ạ Trông cũng
không gì đó phức tạp không ạ Có ở đây có
phân trang và tìm kiếm nữa thôi mặn đi
Ừ thôi bây giờ chắc là chuyện qua sửa
bài Apple nhé Rồi cũng nhanh không
Ừ để anh xem lại cái bài xvideo e
Ừ
nếu không họ gì nữa tôi có hiểu mày
không hiểu bài rồi nhé
ờ ờ
về tôi đẩy đề bài
cho
tôi cài mái nhiều quá khứ lại chẳng thèm
crack nữa chẳng thèm crack
Office kệ
Ừ vậy thôi có ở bài này bài thi của một
ông ở đó đấy ông ấy nhờ nhờ chữa
à à
ở nhà mà tôi hôm đấy tôi chị chữa cho
ông ấy đúng mỗi con một cố hay cho 1 qua
mua gà mái không được lỡ hỏi tôi làm bài
thi hộ hay Vân Tôi rất ghét mình là đi
đấy
anh
nhờ bạn đấy bảo là bạn không theo ngành
này vợ vẫn phải thi
Anh hiểu thi quá more thôi Thế là tôi
đành ở chung trước thôi
Ừ ok ở đây tạo ra tao bay có thể thư
thực á á á tạm nhanh nhé
Ừ tôi có thể tạo từ chính bên A
Ừ cái này để xem à
anh bạn ảo thôi tôi cấu tạo bên mái làm
lại hồi hồi trước hay dậy các bạn bên ai
tạo luôn bởi vì bên này hình như có cả
chích gỡ nữa bên mấy cao cũng có chị cơ
nhưng mà nó sẽ hơi bị khác mình tí
à à
Ừ tôi sẽ dùng cách thêm kiểu được phải
lưu lại
a
v-table động mạnh để lá
à à
chợ hoa
đấy thì như tôi từng nói là các bạn
không nên để tên cục chứa tên bảng Nhưng
tôi sẽ giảm thiểu tất cả những cái điều
đấy nhá
tên này yêu và cha này à
mở cửa hàng ngay hôm nay cái đoạn chị cơ
này nó thay vì kiểu tạo sức gỡ thỏa mãn
không khai khoa trùng tên người ta Các
bạn nghĩ đơn giản là tạo unix là sao
không ạ nhưng mà thôi mình có thể làm
đơn giản à mình cứ làm theo đề bài đúng
ạ
năm thành lập thì ca đây kiểu in Nếu mà
dùng từ năm có những một ngày ạ ngày
thành lập mới từ dự định có nên được
nhưng mình cứ thử xem lại đề bài sao nó
liên quan đến đây năm thành lập ngày
tháng năm này Ok thế thì mình sẽ dùng từ
ngày thành lập vào đây sẽ kiện để cậu đi
không ạ Đây năm thành lập với thứ thử
vẫn hoa nhân ngày tháng năm sinh rồi ok
à bí
quyết table nhânviên à
à à
anh ở đây phải có gì để mà không cái mã
này mã vào chữ đúng thì mình sẽ không để
tự động tăng nữa sẽ là
à mà cha hoặc cha cũng được không ạ
Anh ở mấy ông kia chưa học khóa trên xã
hội tội À đúng rồi hóa chính sách của
tôi không AE chuyên sâu tôi dậy cho mấy
ông để chích cờ cả tôi sẽ đi hết rồi mà
từ khóa 11 mãi à
i10
anh kia chúng tại hơi lớn quá à
thế này sẽ là ngày sinh
là mã khoa
in
A3 tra 10 này
này
mã khóa à
chợ
hoa Nhật Bản
kênh ê
ở trong vẻ đúng
Em dạo này
à à
Ừ ok rồi
ở bệnh nhân nhân viên bệnh nhân
ở bệnh nhân có thêm à
khi ngài nhập ngày suốt
Ừ ok nhàng nhập ngoài suốt
ở trong đó
cả các đánh thức giấy các cột gạch dưới
là cột quá à
Ừ cái được lúc đầu không cho phép tên
qua trùng nhau rồi ông ấy vẫn còn bảo
tạo chung với thời trang ưu điểm gì hơn
buồn cười không sao Kệ
cho bệnh nhân
à à
a mã
em bệnh có thể bệnh Ok bệnh này bận thì
hẳn n vesna 200 cũng được
như tôi ở nó hôm trước Nếu mà quá 255 ký
tự thì mày ông chuyển qua tách thì nó ổn
hơn
vì nếu mà của 255 thì ra cha nó lại
chiếm bộ nhớ nhiều hơn soi tách nên mấy
ông cứ cân nhắc nhé em thể chuyển qua
luôn tech
khi
ngài nhập này Đấy ngày Suốt này à
khi ngài nhập đề xuất dùng tới thiên uy
tín
Ừ ok ở đây sẽ cũng ngồi mã Khoa
Anh tên bệnh nhân không cần
ở cục cột nên cậu ngắn gọn ngay thôi
để lưu lại các thứ chưa đây tôi ngại
nhất ngộ lưu này
hệ thống kê lượt bệnh nhân theo khoa số
lượng ok rồi cưới tại research into khoa
mình có in shop tặng 2 khoa nhé
anh không cần gì tên cột nữa bạn sẽ là
Cột nào phải điện rồi
Zalo này thì sẽ là k01
chợ
hoa nội ngoại
không biết copy Ở đây có nhanh hơn không
ạ
anh kể từ tính xong thì dặm Tôi sẽ chỉ
với ông cách copy cũng nhanh như sau A
à à
Ừ để tôi thử chỉ mấy ông cách copy cái
đoạn này nhanh nhá Ừ
Ừ thôi còn ở đây là cho tất cả đóng vai
cần ạ có nháy
Ừ cái khoảng trống này sẽ
cái khoảng trống này sẽ biến hàng à
ở đâu face
Ừ đúng
méo biết ở Tôi sẽ áp dụng cách gì ở đây
không tôi sẽ dùng rách để làm đoạn này
thì các bạn nhớ khách không ạ thì mình
cần mọi thứ tự trừ dấu cách
anh Sex nghĩa là làm mình sẽ
biến mọi ký tự
đi kèm theo dấu dầu Đúng rồi thay thế
mình sẽ đôi gạch ZicZac tìm đấy nó và
thay thế nó nhưng thay thế Ở đây là mình
thay thế nó Bằng chính nó kết hợp với
thêm dấu nháy thì nó sẽ là các bạn ví dụ
dùng so với tách các bạn ấn thêm cái này
ai có dụng cái này
sau đó thì đầu tiên là mọi ký tự
ờ ờ control hát cần cho nó hát nữa vào
trong sau khi tách thì các bạn sẽ
Đây là một ký tự không ạ mọi thứ tự như
hình như là nó không áp dụng được cho
tiếng Việt này hơi bị khó chịu để tôi
xem
áo khoác amin hệ chưa chọn ngược lại
ngược lại với cái này cũng được cho chắc
ngược lại với cái này nó sẽ có phải ổn
hơn
ở đầu tiên là file cái này một cái Có vẻ
đúng cho đền á Chữ Nội vẫn được ok ok
thử xem nhé
vì nó có mày đúng đây
để tìm hiểu dấu cộng này
chỉ có thế này phải ổn này nhưng trong
trường hợp này mình cần có
anh ở đây mình sẽ là
có thêm cho cách được
cộng lại thử xem nha
Ừ nếu mà mình không muốn có dấu cách ở
cuối này
Ừ Ok mình sẽ là cậu à
anh như này
Ê tôi dậy mấy ông kết hợp với rách không
ạ
anh xem lại
Ừ cái này có thể có không có này là thôi
tôi sẽ ôm bữa nay sang cách 101 cho bé
ông dễ nhìn
Đã
lâu rồi không làm đúng cách quên ok nữa
Ừ cái này có thể có không có này à
có thêm ở dấu này khó chịu nghỉ
có thêm cá sấu này
à à
ở
hà nội thần kinh này cũng có thể lặp đi
lặp lại
ở địa đây mình sẽ đổ đầy là sao này
khi mẹ hỏi chấm hai chấm
ghi chữ nội này
à à đối bên dưới cách bên này thì cái
cái cái chữ nội là nó không được bôi bởi
vì nó uniquat như các bạn thấy rõ ràng
vừa rồi Bên này nó vẫn được bôi nóng bạn
ấy không Sao bên này tí mình vẫn bị play
được em tạm bỏ qua về vụ như cốt ở đây
đúng không ạ
à à
Ừ đúng rồi mày ông có thể chơi chó tạo
tìm khoảng trắng thay thế nó cũng được
cũng là một cách
Ừ ừ cũng là một cách
à à
a
nhớ làm việc tôi tôi đã làm theo hướng
khó thôi là theo Tìm mấy cái này thay
thế thì mới ông sẽ thấy tôi tôi hãy làm
hãy thay thế mọi mấy cái này cùng một
lúc hoặc là tí rồi Hiện chưa cách hay
không Ok tôi sẽ thử hai cách mua cái là
tôi tìm nó khoảng chán rồi tôi say thế
của một cái tôi
tìm chữ của sẽ thay thế Ok cái nào được
mà nó không ạ Mấy ông thích gì cũng chịu
bây giờ là đang giàu chữa bài Con thử
thứ chứ không phải sự dậy nữa
nhà mình có thể đổi cái
Em đổi cái ý cách nhau như này đội nó là
dấu gạch Ok được được rồi được rồi thế
được rồi này đó số tôi sẽ copy vào đây
này mà tôi sẽ thay thế
Ừ cái cúp này cái cụm này tôi sẽ cho nó
vào trong cái móc tròn như thế này để
làm gì
sau khi mà thay thế như này thì tôi sẽ
có đô la một đĩa à cả cái cụ mày sẽ thay
thế được bởi đó là một và tôi sẽ cho
thêm dấu nháy như này thì có thai em mấy
ông xem thử nhé
a fine play play play
Ừ Ok chưa
ở đó thôi Tôi tôi chỉ cần đi play phút
này phát nữa
là cách Bởi dấu phẩy
Em
đã đỡ rồi thì cái này À cái dấu cách ở
đây nó hơi bị bé hơn à Ok Không sao mình
sẽ là cách ra này
Em cộng lại thử tìm nhé
à à
Ừ nếu mà cộng thì có tính ở đấy mất rồi
thì sẽ là ờ
anh thật gà hay dấu cách thôi cũng được
ra mình không quan trọng nhiều cách lắm
Mình có thể hai cách ở đây rồi đây một
dấu phẩy cũng được này
ạ Bây giờ không phải hai cách
ở đây như à
Ừ Ok để tôi thử lại nhé
Ừ cái cách cổ thoại này nó rất là dị mà
nó ạ
Ừ đúng rồi đúng rồi mấy ông cho tròn
Monte Koso cũng được nhưng mà tôi đang
dạy mọi người để ôn lại vậy rồi khách
một tí mà
em thông cảm đó thế này là xong rồi
di chuyển ngay đúng sẽ zplay nó bằng cả
cụm Nhưng ai
bạn có thể thêm cái á với với xuống dòng
như ngày mình sẽ đổi nó là thêm hoặc
tròn
anh tròn cũng được
ở đầu tiên à toàn bộ cái này đi này là
một trò này không ạ
Anh nghĩ là tôi muốn đổi thêm việc làm
khi mà xuống dòng nha này cũng thêm một
tròn thì biết nó làm được điều đấy nó là
ừ ừ
à à
Pro như thế
lý
do không đúng n r
Cho tôi xem
à à
I hate nào thôi nó trong cho mẹ nấu rồi
thì sẽ đổi nó thành giống như này
à à
khoa
học điện ảnh Như này trước đó nghe chưa
ạ
à à
em thừa bắt của em nó không Sao không ra
phổi bị mình mình copy thừa cái đây thừa
phát của Ý
Ừ
đúng nhỉ
à À quên quên vẫn vẫn bị thiếu phải Giàu
đóng này
Anh xóa đi nhá á
có gì nhé Xóa đi Này này ok
khi thiếu vào dấu phẩy đã lại thì lại
quên mất thiếu nó phải mất rồi đấy phẩm
này
à à
cơ
hội như này à
à à
anh đấy Đấy vừa rồi tôi dậy cho mày ông
biết là có có thể áp dụng cách để mà vào
những cái cậu mình làm như thế Khoảng
Cách vừa nãy bạn kia bảo là đổi cái dấu
tát Thành nha dấu phẩy cũng được đúng ạ
Được rồi ta thành dấu phẩy cũng là một
cách kiểu
Ê mày mình sẽ cậu rùng mình cứ cho trước
cái A
D3 mở ngoặc ở đằng đầu rồi đóng ngoặc
bằng đầu sau đó gì
mình sẽ cho mình sẽ chèn cái giấu giấu
cắt của giữa mấy cái hàng này bằng bằng
cả cụ mày này bằng cái nháy rồi dấu phẩy
cũng được không ạ
xe
máy mày không hiểu gì không ạ
mẹ tôi thở lại phát của Nga trong mấy
ông thăm anh nha à
các
bạn chưa bảo tệ là Tab nữa ạ mình lâu bị
chưa dùng cái này được ở đây cũng nó tán
này ok các dịch vụ đây nạng ý bạn đấy là
như thế này này
Ừ thì cứ cho trước và như thế này
ở đó
anh từng dòng cũng từng dòng như này
ừ ừ
Ừ nó sau đó thì mình sẽ đổi t anh ạ ạ
có
phải tem này
Ừ Ok chưa
Ừ cái bị thừa à
anh
lại đổi cái ạ tệ phải tát và trước đó là
mọi dấu cách cho mọi Dậu cách có thể có
cũng nhà như này là được đó nếu không
thấy phải ở cuối lại này cũng được
không ạ
khoa học ghi có lợi mà Mấy ông cứ làm
với cách nhiều mày không giữ mò rất
nhiều cái rất là dịp gặp gỡ ra đây vẫn
thừa rồi cách này hơi bị cay nhưng đại
khái như thế mày không hiểu mà
em mới mò đến cách vui mà hơi bị tốn
thời gian một tí giống như vừa rồi Nếu
mà mày không thấy ít bạn ghi Tôi thả
ngực tay còn hơn nhưng mà thôi nó chỉ em
với ông qua việc thì khỏi tôi chấp nhận
tôi ngồi mò với cách như thế thì mà
không khỏi mình là dân lập trình mình
phải thể hiện gì đó giống như ông kia
vừa 300 bạn ghi hai 3000 mãn cái tôi chỉ
dùng Black chính khóa là xong
Ừ ok
a tiếp theo nhé á
cho tôi lại lỡ control ý
cho
tôi lại lỡ xoài cái đoạn Kiếm mất rồi
đấy ạ
à à
anh buồn off có gì đó Sai sai đấy à quên
quên quên trong Mặc Khải trong hoặc tròn
nhé trong vai trò mới được tính à
Đi bùm nó
thế này
Ừ rồi mẹ ông à
Lại đổi tiếp ở đầu tiên là Tab mày đúng
Ừ rồi bảo giàu cách bị thương rồi này
thì sẽ đổ nho xanh vậy này
có phải phải phải phải phải như vậy ok
rồi này ờ
ạ sau đó nhìn đổi dấu xuống dòng này sẽ
bằng đóng ngoặc này xuống dòng này
phẩm này cho mở ngoặc nè
mà thưởng cái hàng cuối rồi đó xong rồi
Ừ Ok chưa
Ừ ông ấy bảo tôi gì đấy trêu mày ông
Thôi
thì ta chỉ thế nào Alo
tất cả nhân viên à Cái những viên ý
à à
ở đây đúng không mày Ông học lớp 9 để
làm cái gì không phải làm những cái kiểu
như thế này này đúng không
à à
ở trận muốn nhóm ít quá đi à
Em hãy tiếp tục thôi à đi
đái phải lưu lại còn đây
à à
thế
này là vậy này
ở
đây là
anh xuống dòng
à à
Ừ thì sẽ thay à
đóng ngoặc xuống dòng phẩy mở ngoặc
à Xong rồi à
à à
ừ ừ
anh em ơi chiếu n
thiếu nơ gạch trước đúng không thơm sao
a móc khóa được mã vẫn vẫn có cách để
làm được điều đấy vẫn có cách để làm
được đấy Đó là mấy ông cứ đổi ra mấy ông
có thể để chữ nào này trước mọi cái
trước mọi cái dấu nháy thì vẫn được với
trường hợp nó nách còn còn những trường
hợp lại còn lại thì nó không báo lỗi với
nhớ thế
Ừ thôi đại khái như thế thôi đúng không
ạ
Ừ không thì tôi lại copy cái này sang
bên mai que không thì nó sẽ không cần nợ
tách nữa
Ok thống kê số lượng nhân viên theo khoa
cái này thì ra mấy ông quá dễ rồi có một
cổ Hai đúng ạ thống kê về bản chất là số
lượng thì nó sẽ cao sao Thôi không ạ
phạm
những bệnh nhân này nó
Goodbye
mã khóa nếu mà làm theo định kiểu đơn
giản ở như thế này
ở dưới kèm theo cả mã khóa ở đây nữa như
này chẳng hạn
Ừ cái này không ạ số lượng bệnh nhân ở
ngoại ô
ở nhà máy ông sẽ xảy ra ở nhiều người
không không không muốn kiểu dạng là hiển
thị tên tên mã khoa mà hiển thị ra hẳn
tên của Khoa đúng không ạ tên của Khoa
thì đương nhiên là bị sẽ đẻ ra voi mình
sẽ có thể áp dụng hai cách 1 nói cho Hay
sắp đi đây rồi Nó dùng cho vui thôi Thì
ở đây là bệnh nhân nào chắc chắn cũng sẽ
thu khoa đấy là dùng in Android đơn giản
nhất đúng không ạ qua on khóa cho mã qua
làm bệnh nhân
Trần đã Khoa này cái này sau đó thì nếu
mà ông sẽ lách ở đây là Khoa chấm tên
thế này thì cũng sẽ bị lỗi bởi vì à mình
không Mình sẽ không mình không Cái khoa
chấm tên không nằm trong Goodbye không ạ
Các bạn sẽ phải
chị sẽ phải cho thêm cái qua chứng tên ở
trong này nữa như thế này mình chạy được
nhưng mà tôi khuyên là chỉ nên có trường
nào mày xảy ra khi mà khi mà cái cái này
nó bản chất nó không ngừng lặp lại rồi
cái mã Khoa này nó đã cập nó biến hình
cậu nó rút bye được theo cái này đâu rồi
và cái tên nó thương này đi kèm với cả
mã khóa này sẽ không trường hợp sai thì
các bạn vào ứng dụng cái này không ạ
buổi trưa tôi thấy có như ông ăn dụng
thì tưởng như thế này luôn này sai nữa
xe thang sửa máy may nó đúng bởi vì À
cái tên Khoa đang ở duy nhất thôi còn
tên qua mà lặp lại này sẽ lỗi
à à
Em hãy tương tự thế Huế nhân viên nhé nó
quá nhé tạm bạn mới Ảo gồm đầy đủ thông
tin bệnh nhân của bệnh nhân khoa nhi thì
đầu tiên mình cứ lấy toàn bộ thông tin
bệnh nhân quá nhiều ạ Chị sẽ rách sao
Ford bệnh nhân que à
Ừ tôi sẽ làm đoạn này hơi bị sốt tại một
tí nâng cao một tí đó là tôi không dùng
cho hỏi đây dùng supports cho mày hôm
quen đi nay mình sẽ có mã hoa
bằng với
sinx mã for
khoa Này
Where bên trong trường hợp tên ở đây sẽ
là Khoa kiếm tên đi
bằng khoa nhi này chẳng hạn thế
Ừ thì đoạn này đây làm là gì Đầu tiên là
mình sẽ lấy tất cả bệnh nhân có cái mã
khoa bằng với cái mã của Khoa đây là
khoa Nhi không ạ bị cứ lấy hết nhé
chị đã được hai bệnh nhân không ạ thì à
Thì thì bây giờ mình sẽ chỉ việc là cái
riêng tạo bàn Ảo ấy thì cái tạo mảng Ảo
Theo thông tin từ công snack thì nó sẽ
là select into
ở Đông ạ Các bạn tra trên mạng tội không
nhớ lắm tôi ít khi dùng có loại nào ạ
ở những kẹo kẹo như thế này sẽ back into
khi inter của t bản mới từ bản cũ Thế
xong Ừ nó là select into này
ạ sau đó đi Ở đây là bệnh nhân khoa Nhi
không ạ bệnh nhân qua như này
lại như này ra xong
Âm Nhạc Đúng vậy Hãy in shopping Tôi Hà
Nội sẽ access for
anh xex xã hội Youtube ok à
chú chó bơ sẽ xem lại thử tế bào nhé xếp
sau
bảng này
cho tôi tôi chưa biết được cái bảng này
sẽ là có nói trước là nó sẽ đầy đủ tất
cả cột do các bạn sẽ exel như là thì nó
sẽ là copy sang nhiều Tôi chưa biết được
và các bạn có dòng buộc khó mãi la là nó
là bản mới đấy nhé Nó không biết được là
nó có kế thừa cả khó ngoại hãy các từ
thử kia không nhưng mà À đâu rồi Ở đây
là bạn Ảo bạn nào tất cả bảng tạm thôi
thì mình sẽ là dùng cái Ừ Thế này mới
chuẩn này
ở quê lại
Ê mày bây giờ vẫn chạy được không ạ bằng
tặng thôi mình sẽ ra kiểu ngay
có đủ nhà báo cáo bảo tạm thời
à hay là ở Ý bạn đấy sẽ là làm cái view
nhỉ Tôi không biết được cái câu này có
đúng hay không rồi vì câu hỏi chính anh
nó rõ nghĩa hơn tiếng Việt dịch ra nó
không biết được à
cách tạo 1 code thủ tục
khi Dịch hơi bị khô không ạ clickbooth
sẽ điều này danh sách sinh viên không ạ
đánh Xem sinh viên nhân viên
thiết kế đầy đủ thông tin của Khoa đó có
thể truyền tham số tên khoa Ok đây mình
sẽ bỏ tên Thoa ạ
A N và cha 50
love you love you thì thực là dễ thôi Nó
preview for Cái này là xong nó Glad You
ví dụ là bệnh viện khoa nhi đúng không ạ
ạ
sau đó đi gì à á snack sao Phòng như này
là sóng nó
Cô bạn áo người ta review người ta sẽ
không dùng gọi là bạn Ảo lắm Nếu mà tôi
đặt tên nó như thế mà tới nha đừng có
dịch dịch nó cứ bị sai sai không ạ
He has renewed and
Tại mình sẽ chuyển vào cái kiểu ngay
về phần mình sẽ là selex
khi liệt kê đầy đủ thông tin của thì tối
nghĩa là copy đoạn này thì ra có này bạn
chất lỏng giống thôi Cái này đổi đấy
nhân viên thôi cũng là mã khoa đổi đây
là
ở đây là có thể truyền vào là một khoa
Anh tên Khoa nó bạn Tiến qua là xong à
Xong rồi sẽ thử nhé
Anh
tên khoa
bằng quan hệ thôi cũng được ạ
có ra không ạ Cái Các bạn thấy có thời
gian mình không cần thiết hoa không được
Bởi vì thằng axwell này mình nhớ đấy
bằng này nó tương đương gì vậy
ở bảng tương đương có được không viết
hoa ạ
vì nó không phân biệt hóa thường nóng
à Còn nếu mà các bạn muốn cây sen cities
nghĩa là có phân biệt hóa thường cây
xanh xung kích
thì các bạn cứ tra Google Thử xem cái
since It is well tự sáng nó sẽ có những
cái hàm riêng cho để kiểm tra là kỹ hơn
để bắt buộc phân biệt hóa thương
Ừ
đúng rồi Bây giờ Bây giờ ở đâu cũng áp
dụng công nghệ thông tin mà bạn để lưu
lại thông tin khách hàng bệnh nhân có sự
thứ không lưu và quyển quyển hồi trước
còn lưu và tôi không hiểu tôi mất bao
nhiêu cửa sổ nữa Tôi là con người đi
khám bệnh viện nhiều vãi chưởng tôi
không hiểu mất bao nhiêu cây xổ Thư
Vì thế nên à
việc đồng bộ hóa dữ liệu lên mạng cái
thứ
cái này bạn chắc nó cơ sở dữ liệu luôn
mà không ạ Ừ cái này tôi nghĩ là bắt
buộc phải có lâu mình áp dụng vẫn hơi
muộn mai mình cái thời thời cái Ricoh
vít này làm cho kiểu cắt các bộ máy nhà
nước cũng phải thay đổi dần bệnh chuyển
hết về về kiểu phải công nghệ công nghệ
số chứ không thì chắc là lưu toàn bộ hồ
sơ các bạn vẫn còn điểu vẫn còn trên máy
cũ này thôi không lấy mạng này có thứ
chết không ạ
Ôi bạn hỏi Có còn nhiều dự án sử dụng
Apple không Bạn phải hỏi ngược lại với
việc bây giờ đúng là ashworth nó không
mạnh bằng nấu FA vì nó không lưu được
đến hàng triệu hàng tỷ và ghi nhưng mà
khi tất cả những cái thằng lớn nó vẫn
còn phải đang sử dụng atwell bởi vì lập
trình viên mình về FL vẫn rất là đông
thành ra là kiểu và nó vẫn rất dễ học
hơn do nói cây và nó cũng có cái tiện
riêng thế nên là thế nên là gần như là
nó không không thể bị thay thế nó luôn
xong xong thôi mình nghĩ là sẽ không bởi
thể bị thay thế trừ khi có hoàn một
thằng nào đó nó giải quyết vấn đề hơn
cái cái thực ra về axwell này Hôm trước
mình có một cái video mình mới xem đây
có cái kênh này tôi cố định chia sẻ cho
mấy ông sau Nhưng mà Mấy ông hỏi rồi
thôi tôi có chia sẻ nhé Ừ tôi có cái
kênh này
cha có vài bạn biết rồi nó kêu file
highbay phải phải bay file ship nhé
chứ không phải ship phải chứ ạ
Em tải cái này có có Bạn biết rồi bạn
chưa
Ừ cái kênh này à là kênh giải thích giữa
cụ thể kỹ những đứa như bằng tiếng Anh
đôi khi nói khá nhanh nữa
nhưng mà Mấy ông kiểu gì cũng phải quen
dần được nghe và đọc
khi được tài liệu bằng tiếng Anh mày
không bắt buộc phải thế nếu mong theo
ngày này không những bị ông gần chưa bị
tự giới hạn bản thân mình về kiến thức
và tự giới hạn ở mức lương luôn đi em ấy
không phải quen dần đi chắc chắn lúc đầu
trả lại quên cả việc mình mình kiểu gặp
nó hàng ngày tiếp xúc hàng ngày xong rồi
cậu bị bị áp dụng bị hiểu lúc nào thì
nghe thì mới ông bị quen dần thôi giống
như tôi chơi game rõ ràng hội đầu mấy
ông chơi game có đầy game làm gì có
tiếng Việt đâu bé ông vẫn kiểu quen dần
nó nó không ạ Nó vẫn biết học cách chơi
thôi Bởi vì sao phải không ai thuốc ông
này đấy thì ông sẽ tự mày mò về ông cảm
thấy ông hứng thú không ạ
anh nói chung và cái cách này Hôm trước
mình có xem về cái vụ esquare trái phép
tại đây là không
Đây đây đôi khi có những cái video nó
dậy hết cho 100 giây này nó rất là cuốn
luôn đúng 100 đây luôn nó giải thích từ
đầu đến cuối
Anh khá rõ và Đây này cái mà tôi đi mày
tập video này nó là 77 loại 7 loại
database Nếu dung dịch thu kiểu na ná
như thế
bởi loạn tao bay nó từ kiểu tao bay đơn
giản theo kiểu là vây kiểu là là
key-value cho nó thì vân vân sao cũng có
liên quan rác này sự liên quan hệ Wow
này mà nấu với cô không có phải chơi cả
multi-modal có thể thử lại cái video hỏi
Rất hay nhưng mà Mấy ông phải đấy giống
như giống như đầu đầu với môn học này
tôi có nói đó là mấy ông ạ
Ê mày ông phải kiến thức phải nó đa nền
một tí thì mới ông mới xem được mấy cái
này trước mấy ông không chuyên sâu mấy
ông nghe cái này xong bé ông bị bị
choáng đấy thì có rất nhiều cái trong
này nói ông không hiểu đâu còn mấy ông
muốn xem qua để cho biết qua ấy giống
như giống như tôi bảo là ông cứ thử biết
qua để xem có phù hợp cái đấy không ấy
ông lên xem của cái kênh này cái 100
giây của nó nó giải thích một cách rất
rất là kiểu đầy đủ đầy đủ nhé Chỉ cho
100 giây mà đầy đủ toàn bộ về cơ bản của
một cái gì đó làm cho cảm thấy là cậu
rất là hưởng thụ kiểu ông ông xem ông
nghe được đầy đủ của một cái gì đó Mở có
bạn thôi không phải chuyên sâu được đúng
ạ Mà ông thấy hiểu Dễ hiểu vòng thấy à
có thể hấp dẫn lâu thì ông treo rồi đấy
được
vì nó rất nhiều cái tôi chưa hề biết tôi
xem được 100 giây nó thôi hiểu qua được
với nó
đi theo tôi khẳng định được cái kênh này
làm nói chung và chất lượng tốt nhiều
người biết mà
chỉ cần 1 triệu rồi
Ừ tôi không mở lên để mày không lấy mạnh
quyền đâu
ừ ừ
Ừ Ok tạm thủ tục của tên là truyền
anh hỏi cái này đơn giản này tôi bỏ qua
nhé Tặng khi cơ Nhanh nhé à
Ừ thế là không ai tạo cái cơ để mà làm
cái vụ này như tôi nói lúc đầu mình tạo
sử unique là do đúng không ạ Nhưng nếu
mà ông vẫn muốn kiểm tra theo vợ
Ồ thông báo thì dở in sơ vào
Em in ra và một bản ghi làm theo của một
lần ghi trước bạn nhé
tạo chị đơ không ạ
A là
ừ ừ
à à
Chú Chó nhà mình nói như cả hơi tía
xuống song ca
Ừ thôi chỗ trọ I
Ờ Ờ
nói chung là không ai tạm trữ theo kiểu
như thế
nhưng mà cứ thử tạo thì mình sẽ là có
thêm
hoàn không ạ
khi con
on on ăn nha khoa này
ô tô quyền sử mày có đấy rồi instead of
này
Insert thức là nó bao gồm à update nữa
Ừ anh cứ tạm thế đã ghi em
mình sẽ mình có thể là mình xét
à à sex ngủ đi
a z tên Khoa
a =
sinx Pain from research
nữa à
I eat
Anh tên
thì mình sẽ kiểm tra nhé hai mình sẽ là
mình kiểm tra xem nó đã tồn tại hay chưa
Nó là cái j mà kiểm tra tồn tại Chíp sẽ
lệch à
ờ ờ
anh đợi mình xem nhé Mình nhớ cái cậu ấy
giúp nó nhà
máy Apple này
à à
a Where is it
anh không có xe nicky's thì phải
khi mà quen nó tin cũng được
a where
Một mình chị theo kiểu như thế nào đây
ở đây mình có thể chơi trò là sẽ lấy kẹo
được
anh sex
đếm chủ nhà triệu in bằng
ax
cao sao
khi
con Hoa
Where tên bằng đùa tên nhà chẳng hạn Nếu
mà đến chung
bằng không
thì tức à Không dùng chưa chưa có cả
chúng tên này cả thì mình sẽ là kiểu rất
vào thôi ông ạ
Ừ thì sẽ là
Insert into
khoa Solex sao for instant và sợi rất là
Ừ bạn em là ngược lại đúng ạ nhau là
mình sẽ kiểu pin làm cái gì đó các bạn
thể thì bị ghi mà em là đấy sắc cú hiểu
Nó là cái mũ hoặc hoặc của Apple không ạ
ạ
anh sạc pin đây là à a trung rồi ạ
Đây là mình làm vẫn kiểu rất là đơn giản
theo kiểu là chỉ có
chị có kiểu kiểu là kiểm tra một hàng
thôi chúng mình chưa làm việc cởi rất
được nhiều cùng lúc đi
khi xét nhà đúng nhỉ Lâu lắm rồi tôi
không mà đi clip Vậy à
ừ ừ
Ừ thôi đừng có lại đi Clans
cách tạo này
Ừ Ok Bye mình sẽ mình có sẽ rách sao
form khoa Phát nữa để xem có khoa như
nào
Có ai có khoa nhi không bình thường
Insert into hoa
balo cho nó ra sự là mã khác đi
k10
khoa nhi
từ ngày phá mày à
anh
đi suốt này
a trung rồi đúng ạ Các bạn là có cách để
mà tắt cái vụ là kiểu hiển thị ra có bao
nhiêu dòng bị ảnh hưởng này thì ra bao
nhiêu dòng này b là nó không có ý nghĩa
gì nữa thì nó không chạy đâu Nên là các
bạn có cách tắt này dụng cái Hà mà xét
nấu cao ấy sẽ lâu cao
svhouse để nó tắt cái hiển thị này đi
đấy thì à
à còn nếu là các bạn muốn là Miss rất
nhiều cùng một lúc được cậu là cái Khoa
này trùng nhờ mình không cho Asus như
còn khoa khác thì không chung qua nhi
đồng nhìn lạ
như thế này không chồng mình vẫn cho in
Search thì cái này thì nhớ báo lỗi vì
cái câu select này nó trả về nhiều hơn
một giá trị ngoãn Thì cái này nó sẽ lỗi
ngoại thì cái vụ đấy thì chắc cả các bạn
cứ nghiên cứu thêm mình lại thấy à Hôm
nay video hơi dài mà chữa các bạn có cố
Sao lại rồi Các bạn cứ
làm thử làm thử ở trên tekla bồ rồi mình
sẽ xem bạn nào đúng là mình sẽ chữa
riêng và thằng bạn thì mình nghĩ sẽ ổn
hơn còn video hôm nay mình vẽ các bạn
tạm ổn tại đây đã vì hôm nay mình mình
chỉ 1 chữa các bạn được cơ bản thôi ông
ạ
Ừ thế đã ổn chưa hay mới Ông còn chữ Lâu
rồi có sao
anh alo mày không mất tích hay rồi Vừa
nãy lên 100 bạn rồi cùng sau sinh do
sóng vậy tôi nghĩ thể chữa thêm tí nữa
Chẳng còn ai mất
anh alo alo Mày không đâu hết rồi alo
em còn đang nói chuyện ấy
Ừ tự nhiên không thấy ông nào bình luận
nữa rồi Tôi bị đánh mặt tiền nhà
anh giải tiếp đi á ông ta vẫn dài tiếp
vậy Nếu máu ấy
Ừ rồi anh nhé mà Chữa nốt thì ở đây thì
mình thì mình sẽ không cần phải đến cái
này nữa có cách ngắn hơn đó là mình sẽ
chỉ Insert đây mình sẽ câu này rất là
Này Where tên Note in
a snack Pain for for khoa Thế là sau này
ạ
Ừ thế là xong
ý chạy thử
a e quyết or enter
A chạy
à Xong rồi
Ừ nhưng mà tại sao tại sao lại lại nhanh
như thế có thể chỉ đơn giản là kiệm mình
sẽ lấy lấy tất cả những cái từ cái mình
sẽ Asus số ngồi với điều kiện là tên
quen tên mình sẽ lại tên nằm trong khoa
nó không ạ thì mình sẽ kiểm tra lần lượt
tên này có không được nằm trong cái hoa
thì mình mới được ký giữa thế thôi
a nhớ đây nhược điểm là các bạn phải
thêm cái thông báo cho người dùng nữa là
những cái trường hợp trường hợp nào
không được Insert nữa các bạn để select
lại cái trình cái đoạn này là trường hợp
này không được những xót chẳng hạn gì đó
cậu kiểu thông báo rồi như thế này cho
đẹp này nhá Thử nhé
Huy Này
những
những khoa đã đi Shop đã thêm lại dụng
từ chuyên nghiệp
là như thế này và những khoa
bị chung nhiều ẩn ý
à à
Ừ
cái này là xong
ở đó
Thật sự em trường hợp như lai
thế hả Quên Người Quên nít nó làm cái
này cơ hơi bị cay
nó như mày không hiểu cho tôi không ạ
nghĩa làm chứ có thể làm in ra đi là
xong báo cho người dùng đó làm chị là
những cái này đã thêm này những cái này
bị lỗi này cậu như thế thì trải nghiệm
người dùng sẽ tốt hơn thay vì người dùng
chẳng biết được câu Insert vừa rồi nó
rất vu vơ nó không nó thông báo thành
công nhưng mà tăng ca không biết là
thành công thế nào đúng đấy Ok chưa
à Còn nếu mà ngắn gọn theo kiểu đề bài
nói tao chỉ cần như thế này đủ rồi đấy
áp dụng trong mọi trường hợp cái rớt một
hay nhiều bạn ghi nó nhọn
Ừ thế nhỉ mày không còn thắc mắc gì nữa
mở bài bài này bài thi nhưng mà cái này
là do là
mình thấy thấy ca do trường đấy cậu cha
dạy cũng mức tương đối cơ bản thôi bài
thi ạ Các bạn thì mới Ông thấy tất cả có
sao Nóng chị đi làm thế này không ạ
Ừ Ok tạm rồi thế nhá Cha có bạn thắc mắc
gì Các bạn lại bình luận rồi mình sẽ
giải đáp sau nhé
Ừ thôi chả các bạn nhé
nấu gì lâu là não lại động đẩy rồi Nóng
ạ Các bạn phải xem mạng video có thêm lý
do này mà video tôi được nhiều lượt xem
hơn cái cách mà không ạ
Em đừng có lũ quá không xem lại
thôi chả đó bạn
ừ ừ